nos dicen graficar una línea con
pendiente igual a menos 2 que contenga
el punto 4 menos 3 y tenemos aquí
nuestro widget de gráficos de khan
academy donde solo tenemos que encontrar
dos puntos en esa línea y la graficar a
para nosotros pausa este vídeo e incluso
si no tienes acceso al widget en este
momento aunque todo está disponible en
canadá academy al menos piensa en cómo
abordaría es esto y si tienes papel y
lápiz te invito a que trates de graficar
esta línea por tu cuenta antes de que yo
trabaje con esto muy bien hagámoslo
juntos sabemos que contiene el punto 4
menos 3
supongo que podrías decir que es la
parte fácil solo tenemos que encontrar
el punto x igual a 4 y menos 3 así que
es desde el origen 4 a la derecha y 3
hacia abajo pero luego tenemos que
averiguar dónde podría estar otro punto
porque si pudiéramos averiguar otro
punto entonces podríamos graficar la
línea y la clave aquí es que la
pendiente es igual a menos 2 de modo que
una manera de pensar en esto
comenzará en el punto que sabemos que
está en la línea y una pendiente de
menos 2 nos dice que a medida que x
aumenta en 1 que disminuye en 2 el
cambio en jet será de menos 2 y entonces
este podría ser otro punto en la línea
así que podría graficar lo así si x
aumenta en 1 x pasa de 4 a 5 y que
cambiará en menos 2 entonces se cambiara
de menos tres a menos 5 y lo hicimos
acabamos de graficar esa línea ahora
otra forma en que podrías hacerlo porque
a veces es posible que no tenga ese
espacio en el papel o en el widget para
poder ir a la derecha para que x aumente
y es ir por el otro lado si tienes una
pendiente de menos 2 otra forma de
pensar es si x disminuye en 1 entonces
aumenta en 2 pero recuerda la pendiente
es el cambio en g sobre el cambio en x
por lo tanto podrías decir que tiene un
cambio positivo de 2 en y cuando x tiene
un cambio negativo o puedes pensar que
cuando x tiene un cambio positivo que
tiene un cambio de menos 2
pero en cualquier caso tienes la misma
línea fíjate que esta línea es la misma
tanto si lo hiciéramos de la primera
forma si tuviéramos x subiendo en una
unidad y rebajando en dos es exactamente
la misma línea